[Musique]
je polygame moi Alice de Lanin dans ha
Galo et là il m'envoie un Tex je te
l
attends au secours viens me chercher
adieu c'est tout quoi
il est fragile il a pété un
C Lola de ver dans mince
àorz prendre va très bien
[Musique]
merci je me
mène Julien dans
camilleou
[Applaudissements]
bouour il est à poil dans la cours du
lycée au bout d'une laisse je te mets
ton cul à la place de ta gueule et je
vois quelle note ça te fait pas mal
oui India r dans Camille redouble je
vous l'avais
demandé vous êtes sûr oui vous avez pas
plutôt passé votre temps à écrire votre
journal intime à confisser vos malheurs
de puelle hystérique à l'encre bleue des
mers du Sud et à dessiner plein de
petitœur maman c'est toi qui a raison
c'est toi qui a raisonin dans mauvaise
fille tu as raison la crème j'aime ça la
crème c'est ma passion numéro 1 dans la
vie la crème j'adore la crème j'adore la
crème de laapéro
[Musique]
là et le César du meilleur espoir
féminin ainsi qu'une paire de chauss en
argent magique de Céline Dion sont
attribué quelle taille la paire de
chaussures 44
fillette la
mienne à
isiaelin
fille et que sa mère est atteinte de
grave maladiie c'est en l'voyant sur
scène recevoir sa première victoire de
la musique que Patrick m l'a imaginé
dans le rôle il s'agit de sa toute
première apparition au cinéma et c'est
une habituée des récompenses elle a déjà
obtenu de victoires de la musique en
2010 album rock de l'année et révélation
sur scène et une en 2012 pour très
album est le prier cés de cette
[Musique]
soirée ça
Mar bonsoir j'ai fait du 41 un peu juste
mais merci infiniment je suis
extrêmement ému extrêmement touché je
vous remercie l'Académie d'avoir voté
pour moi je remercie du fond de mon cœur
Patrick
m pour m'avoir permis de réaliser voilà
c'est un peu con mais mon rêve
et je remercie bien évidemment Justine
Levy aussi je remercie toute l'équipe du
film qui a été tellement tellement
tellement
tellement cool avec moi Carole Bouet
Arthur Dupont Bob galdov ainsi que voilà
tous les autres parce que voilà je sais
que vous me vous m'entendez quand je
vous le dis voilà donc je remercie aussi
les producteurs Dimitri Rassam Michel
alberstad et Laurent Pétin et c'est trop
bien merci voilà la musique toujours et
maintenant le cinéma j'espère aussi
beaucoup voilà je vais aller danser seu
dans un coin maintenant
merci
[Musique]